- [Derek] For some people,
this room might be the
scariest place on earth.
Behind these black curtains
are deadly spiders,
(tense ominous music)
hundreds of them.
And what we're gonna do is
poke them, make them angry,
and then suction the venom
that appears at the end
of their really long fangs.
Well, this is about as close
as I ever want to get to a funnel-web.
And we're doing it for a very good reason.
This is a funnel-web spider.
They live around Sydney,
which just happens to be one
of Australia's biggest cities,
and they build underground burrows,
which are distinctive,
because of the funnel shape
of the web at the entrance,
hence the name funnel-web.
But because they feel
safe in dark, cool places,
they can end up having
unexpected run-ins with people.
- What happens is during
the breeding season,
the male funnel-web will leave his burrow,
and he moves around only at
night, looking for the females,
but sometimes he gets, you
know, a bit adventurous,
and he might leave his
burrow, go too far from it,
and so in the morning, once
the sun starts to come up,
he's too far from his
burrow to go back to it,
so he kind of has a little freak out,
and has to find somewhere
temporary to hide out
during the day.
And so what he'll do is
he'll head into a nice, dark,
safe spot, like a pile of clothing,
or a pair of shoes on the ground.
- [Derek] You'll often see Australians
bang their shoes together
before putting them on just in case.
If you are unlucky enough to
get bitten, it'll be painful,
because their fangs can be
up to one centimeter long,
that's longer than many snake fangs,
and the venom delivered
is fast-acting and deadly.
- We only milk the males,
because they are six times more toxic,
so the males venom actually produces
a higher quality anti-venom.
So the fastest time that
we've seen an adult die
from a male funnel-web
spider was about 76 minutes,
so just over an hour.
So it's a very fast-acting, rapid venom.
- Ideally, you wanna stay calm, still,
and apply a pressure
immobilization bandage,
and then get to the hospital
as soon as possible.
The venom contains a mixture of proteins,
notably the delta hexatoxin.
As it travels through your bloodstream,
you'll begin to sweat, twitch,
salivate, and get goosebumps.
This is because the venom
acts on nerve cells, neurons.
Under normal conditions,
neurotransmitters trigger
neurons to open ion gates,
and positively-charged
sodium ions flood in.
The dramatic swing from
negative to positive
triggers the release of neurotransmitters
to the next neuron, and
then the ion gates close,
and the cell returns to its resting state,
but funnel-web venom stops
the ion channels from closing.
So the neuron unleashes a
flood of neurotransmitters,
like adrenaline, throughout
the nervous system.
So muscles, normally
under precise control,
receive rapid chaotic signals
causing them to tense up or spasm,
which is a big problem for the heart,
which begins to pump faster,
raising blood pressure,
and spreading the venom
further around the body,
and eventually your body runs
out of neurotransmitters.
Without them, nerve cells
can no longer tell muscles
what to do,
so you're effectively paralyzed,
and it's only a matter
of time before your heart
or your lungs give out.
(slow tense music)
Humans are particularly unlucky,
funnel-web venom is not
that deadly to most mammals.
- If something like your dog, or your cat,
or a rabbit gets bitten by a
male funnel-web spider even,
even the male, they'll
show very few symptoms
and then you could also be
bitten by the exact same spider,
and be in a very severe way.
- [Derek] And that's
because the effects of venom
are very species specific.
Delta hexatoxin binds to a specific site
of the sodium ion channels in
primates, which causes chaos.
But that same spot isn't
there in other mammals.
The lethality of this venom in humans
seems to be an accident.
- It only affects invertebrates,
which are their prey and also primates,
so it's really toxic to monkeys, and apes,
and of course, we are extremely
badly affected by that.
- The first people
arrived on the continent
around 70,000 years ago,
but this spider evolved
40 million years ago,
and it just happens to be
extremely deadly to people.
So it seems like an
unfortunate coincidence
that venom originally evolved
for effectiveness against insects
turns out to be deadly for us.
The people here at the
Australian Reptile Park
try to prevent that by making
life-saving anti-venom,
but to produce it
requires collecting venom
from their stock of spiders.
- [Jake] We actually
rely exclusively almost
on public donations in order
to keep the collection going.
All of these spiders
would've been caught up
by someone that has found
it in their backyard,
or in their swimming pool,
or something like that.
- You heard right,
funnel-web spiders can
actually survive underwater
for up to 30 hours.
They do this by trapping tiny air bubbles
in the hairs on their abdomen.
So if you see a funnel-web spider
at the bottom of a swimming pool
that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's dead.
- It's much more efficient
for us to have spiders
handed in that are already adults,
they're moving around,
they're mature males,
and we can start milking
them straight away,
we haven't had to do any
of the work to raise them.
And then, yeah, we'll milk
them for that period of time.
- [Derek] Here's how you do it.
First, you poke it.
- [Jake] So that's kind
of the funnel-web spider defensive stance,
they'll raise in the air like
that, and expose their fangs.
Sometimes they'll actually
form drops of venom
just on the tip of each fang
- [Derek] Which is when we
come in with a tiny vacuum.
- [Jake] You basically just
use it as you would a pencil,
and just stroke the tip
of the fang with that.
- [Derek] Okay, I see
that I got a little bit.
- [Jake] Sucked a big drop up.
- [Derek] Well, this is about as close
as I ever want to get to a funnel web.
- Say we milk about 50 spiders a day.
If you were saying each spider
produced four to five drops,
you know you're only talking
about maybe 250 drops of venom.
What we've got in the end
of the pipette there now
would be enough to kill perhaps
a dozen or so adult humans.
- To get one vial of anti-venom,
they have to milk 150 spiders by hand.
That takes 12 hours.
12 hours out.
- It's a lot of work.
- Milking a spider
to save one person.
- Exactly, yeah.
- I mean I think that's worth it.
The venom is frozen, and sent
down to a lab in Melbourne,
and there rabbits are injected with it.
Now, although it's not as toxic to rabbits
as it is to humans,
they still start with a low dose,
and then over a period of six months,
they gradually increase the dose
as the rabbits build up their immunity,
and once they can withstand
six times the lethal dose,
their blood is collected,
and it gets spun on a centrifuge
to separate out the antibodies.
And it is these rabbit antibodies
that form the life-saving anti-venom.
Rabbits and people are similar enough
that rabbit antibodies can still
neutralize funnel-web venom
inside our bodies.
Every year around 40 people get bitten
by funnel-web spiders
commonly from not checking
their shoes in the morning.
- And fortunately, due to this program,
no one has died since 1981.
So for over 40 years now,
we haven't seen a single death from one
of these spiders.
- Before we end today,
I want to thank today's
sponsor, BetterHelp.
BetterHelp's mission is to
make therapy more accessible
to more people,
and I think that's a
really important goal.
You know, finding a
good therapist is hard,
especially when you only have
the options in your city.
And it can be even harder to find time
in your schedule to
travel in and meet them.
BetterHelp changes the game on all this,
it's an online platform, it's remote,
and by filling out a few questions,
you'll get matched to a
professional therapist,
and if you don't really
fit with that therapist,
which is a common thing,
you can easily switch
to a new one for free
without stressing about insurance,
who's in your network,
or anything like that,
regardless of if you have a
clinical mental health issue,
like depression or anxiety,
or if you're just a human
being who lives in this world
who has fears or stresses
therapy can give you tools
to approach your life
in a very different way,
and it's easy to sign up,
there's a link in the description
which is betterhelp.com/veritasium.
Clicking on that link
help support this channel,
but it also gets you
10% off your first month
at BetterHelp, so you can try it out,
and see if it works for you.
So I wanna thank BetterHelp
for sponsoring Veritasium
and I want to thank you for watching.